okay um there's your heading now what if
I can do is having made that heading if
you've got especially if you've got a
loose-leaf
um go back to the first question we did
yesterday I think that was Johnny and he
didn't didn't throw it I think he just
took his corn Queen weight and he just
dropped it remember that yeah okay go
back to that question now remind me what
questions did we ask about that scenario
what are we interested in he said he
dropped it off the edge of a building if
I remember right we didn't know how tall
it was just a building indeterminant
height but what did we ask I think was
like yeah good okay so after a certain
amount of time has passed okay we were
interested in displacement in
displacement and velocity
okay good now let's extend this a little
bit further I think wait sorry remind me
yet what were the answers I think for a
velocity we got how many meters per
second
what are we going - 40 49 okay and how
far to go it's like 120 - okay good
all right now what we've got from this
answer is some things about this
scenario that are frozen in time okay
now what I do is change the question of
the lip same scenario
okay and see how relates to something
but you actually know in calculus very
very well but we haven't committed to
motion yet okay so so say after five
seconds I'd like to know I'm gonna think
about this better how far how far has
the point how far is the coin traveled
between five and the next five seconds
so in other words ten seconds okay so I
want to know how far travels in the
second lot of five seconds right he
drops it
five seconds past then we start a um
well a measuring thing we've got that
spot let travel another five seconds
where does it get to okay now what will
we need to know in order to work out in
order to solve this question how far
have we travel in that time what exit
things we need to know okay since we
already know where the coin is after
five seconds all I need to work out that
actual distance right is where it is a
ten okay so when T is equal to ten
that's you
what do we get for displacer what is our
equation for a special is it minus 4.9 T
squared yeah
and what was that costume do we have a
constant no we didn't have constant
right because we started at the origin
okay I'm sorry
sorry well this is a general one so
let's substitute 10 in there okay so
that's minus 4.9 times our hundred right
sir - 490 okay of course there's a
number does it make sense
is it a sensible answer I think it is in
some ways it might seem counterintuitive
because you're like it took me five
seconds to travel this far and then in
another five seconds it goes a lot
further right like almost three times
further between there and there but
that's the way acceleration works yeah
okay
now therefore to get to this answer then
what am I going to do with these two
from my T equals ten now I'm gonna take
this far they look like a deal just
going to take the difference yeah so I'm
gonna one way to say it is total
distance is equal to where I am at the
end which is X of 10 remember X is a
function okay - xo5 okay now just before
I go on and finish the working for that
just be careful the reason why we can do
this okay is because and this is the
right reason why I picked the example
okay the coin it travels and it never
changes direction yeah it's always going
into the same - never it's monotonically
decreasing if you're like right that's
the reason why I can use this if the
coin miraculously change direction
okay turned around somehow I don't know
a bird quarter or something okay this
this wouldn't be able to couldn't use
this approach why not
ah okay right so this is displacement is
a vector yes so it has it's all about
distance from an a regional place it
doesn't tell you necessarily how far you
travel okay so for instance if you've
got a oh yeah you've got a person and
they're running laps around the oval
okay and they run around and around and
around and around if you have a look at
the displacement function how long does
it take you to run around the oval say
two minutes okay on a good day t equals
zero you'll be at the origin antique was
to you'll be back at the origin okay
so if you did this kind of thing your
total distance would be zip and you'll
get really depressed like how the two
minutes I didn't achieve anything so we
can use this kind of approach because if
there's no change in direction okay but
later on when there are changing the
direction you'll see we have to use a
bit more of a sophisticated approach
with a graph okay all right now anyway
this is - for 90 - - I'm gonna highly
recommend that you don't shortcut this
step here don't write plus okay even
though it is plus because it's so easy
to get mixed up with directions and all
so what this shows is you understand
what's going on you're taking a
difference that's what subtraction means
okay all right what's it equal to three
sorry all right so there's our answer
not too dramatic okay but I wonder if
you can see what this process has to do
with this which we haven't introduced
yet to do with motion okay can you see
that this line here see that okay that's
basically a definite interval that's
what we're doing with a definite
integral right we would probably write
it like this you've got some kind of you
integrate something then you get it to
resolve right we're calling that X and
then you evaluate it between upper and
lower bounds right like so okay does
that make sense
so in other words we can actually
approach this question without knowing
this this is one appointment to get our
distance right you taught me about the
displacement equation it's fair to here
okay but to know how far I've gone I
don't actually need to know displacement
I can just use velocity you see how it
works because we got X just as a an
integral of V right we said X is equal
to the integral of feed right so
therefore I can say in the total
distance in this case is the integral
from 5 to 10 those are the times I'm
interested in right off my velocity
function ok now why do I do this why
introduce a definite integral when it
was just as easy for us to say ok where
am I at 10 and where am I at 5 but the
advantage of this has is number one you
don't need to know what the actual
displacement function is ok see here you
know we had to work out where this
constant was it was zero in this case in
the next question it was like 40 or
something like that ok so that takes a
little bit of extra work to work out
what that constant is why doesn't it
matter think back to definitely to it
once you work out the constant if you
pop it in okay you added it and then you
have to subtract it again because the
Closen is the same in both of these
cases ok so that's why you know we
learned indefinite integrals you don't
have to worry about the constant what
that means here is if you want to work
out the total distance okay as opposed
to am a displacement function you don't
need to worry about this displacement
equation okay just take velocity and use
a definite integral so you can use these
memories and you can do exactly the same
with the acceleration right if you want
to work out a total change of velocity
between time II is five and time goes
ten how much of my sped up okay how much
is my speed changed
okay we could have taken the tape
approach who could say well my velocity
at this point at T equals five was - way
night you work it out at equals ten and
then you take the difference okay but we
could just say integrate from five to
ten the acceleration function okay so
you see this is this total change and
this total distance is really the same
question this area right when you're
working out area under a curve
that's what definite integrals stand for
all right so to help you get your brain
around blowing this isyes
but last night I'm gonna give you on a
tuna mission I said you're not better